the intrepid probes geostationary orbit
is stable at an altitude of 300 42
kilometers above Mars you ask me
tomorrow to expect faster in parts of
1953 a.m. this morning I'm pleased to
report that all systems are nominal on
Mars man craft launch countdown
initiated
why are we running for launch five hours
early all right so it's a better launch
window I can see that but who authorized
it
[Music]
as you can join we have a visual on Mars
race for our entry engage artificial
intelligence support commencing search
of the rotation we do
crash investigation should include the
government's need investing later people
need answers the families need answers
the people can wait
good morning mission supervisor
Mackenzie Wilson
good morning arty I'm pleased to report
that all systems are nominal on the Mars
Lander craft let's see if we could find
out what happened let's give it a shot
launch countdown initiated why are we
launching five hours early who
authorized it I did Artie's taking lead
on the crash investigation you are
living in his world now we created AI to
help us not to beat us they ever needs
to be smart not human I have an origin
unknown what are we looking at buckle up
for you artificial intelligence or alien
intelligence be prepared for every
possible danger warning
unidentified satellite detected firing
please tell me I'm hallucinating sorry
McKenzie I mission controller a we
friends who knows what is capable of
[Music]
this is an international incident no no
no you have to stop them
the human race must adapt or perish
it's everything we were warned about
[Music]
you